hey guys i'm ryan right like i said in a
previous video i'm currently in san
diego had to introduce a film at
comic-con called circle rather good
movie actually so I'm an SD right now
and I'm staying at a friend's place but
of course people want me to check out
some videos it's the beautiful thing
about my work I can watch trailers
anywhere I go anyway I'm going to be
checking out the video I'm going to be
checking out street fighter 5 can reveal
trailer and I just so happened to be
wearing my Ryu sure not my or Ryu shirt
not Mya my Ken shirt I don't have a
candy shirt Oh PlayStation call you
nice
it looks more calming
but off right now
fives a good number it sounds good with
a franchise that is um peek at the end
that was for the the worm re its ma Ori
I remember the spelling on my good at
pronouncing [ __ ] from New Zealand like
the face paint and dreads is what kind
of reminding me of it I thought it was
Mewtwo at first I'm not gonna lie it was
a [ __ ] idiot but I'm pretty sure
that's what it is but then again it kind
of looks like a female Blanca I knew a
female named Blanca real [ __ ] something
tells me that people are going to be
upset about Kens hair as he kind of
looks like Fei Long in a way but like
blonde hair her like a blonde on blonde
hair but like a blonde wig like I don't
know why but I get the impression that
people aren't gonna be a little
dissatisfied with the way Ken looks
personally it doesn't really bother me
too much I think a lot of people forget
that can actually has japanese blood in
him too so it's okay that he looks a
little Fei Long II i love street fighter
4 i own the game no matter how many
characters i'm constantly being
introduced to rio always ends up my
favorite at the end of the day 10 you
know is often compared for obvious
reasons i'm watching this trailer and
I'm like you know what I kind of want to
play as can a little bit more than were
you I don't know who I pissed off by
saying that but that is how I feel
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel if you're new to it you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine because if we get more
followers we can get even more product
listen Adrian Sanchez hey Ryan can I get
a shout-out please I love you guys hope
to meet you all one day PS Ryan you are
one awesome [ __ ] yes I am yes i
am i've never [ __ ] a mother but you
know maybe one day my girlfriend will
get pregnant and then
when we have the baby and I sleep with
her then I could be a mother [ __ ]
Veronica she kind of reminds me of my
girlfriend then he sent me a picture of
his girlfriend she's pretty
congratulations you got a 4 you're just
like me mad like you don't deserve
someone so good-looking I just look at
you and you spend your time on YouTube
that you don't deserve someone as good
looking as the girl that you have and
you're saying she looks like Veronica ok
ok ok now we're getting into different
territory here if you want to come I
said your girlfriend's pretty but fun
compared to my girlfriend whoa you put
those two in a beauty contest my
girlfriend wins ok to prove it I'll see
if I can get them to hook up with each
other